we're going to begin this hour with
ukraine and a dramatic escalation in the
crisis there russia's military confirms
this morning that the country's nuclear
forces have indeed been put on high
alert president vladimir putin calls it
a response to quote aggressive
statements by nato leaders
take a look at these images from the
city of kharkiv where intense fighting
has kept russian forces at bay at least
for now this morning crisis talks are
underway at the ukraine belarus border
democratic senator chris [ __ ] serves on
the senate foreign relations committee
uh and he went to europe last week to
meet with leaders of nato countries and
the president of ukraine and he joins us
now senator good morning you're also on
the judiciary committee and we do want
to get to supreme court questions later
but we're going to begin with ukraine uh
you met with leaders in europe you're
also close with our leader here
president biden what can you tell us
about where the white house is right now
in terms of the crisis as it stands and
where it might be going
well the hard work that president biden
did over the last year to weave back
together our nato alliance has been
paying off uh last week when i met with
leaders from across europe uh and this
week as we've seen the remarkable
courage and determination of president
zielinski we've also seen a swift and
united response to russian aggression
and that's partly a result of president
biden's effective diplomacy the eu for
the first time is paying for offensive
weapons to be sent into ukraine germany
has reversed course is cutting off the
nordstrom 2 pipeline that russia was
counting on for future revenue and is
sending offensive military weapons into
ukraine and i serve on the
appropriations committee we're going to
provide billions more in assistance both
for refugees and for the ukrainian
resistance
so senator looking into the future the
ukrainians are putting up a very fierce
fight but they are outnumbered they are
outgunned even with that additional aid
the russian military is very strong if
putin succeeds in taking some sort of
control of the country what does the us
need to do now to prepare
well first president biden has said over
and over that we will defend every inch
of nato territory last week i had the
chance to meet with american and polish
pilots
and with american and lithuanian armored
troops who are training together and
preparing for the potential defense of
nato against russian aggression
second we have to make sure that the
eastern flank of nato is fully
reinforced president biden has
dispatched 12 000 u.s troops to make
sure that putin understands there is a
real red line he cannot cross and last
we're going to have to continue to
support the people of ukraine they will
ultimately succeed i think this will be
putin's greatest mistake and ultimately
because of the thousands and thousands
of protesters across europe and russia
and the significant economic harm that
we're already seeing to russia i think
this move will end up being his greatest
mistake
many people hope you're right about that
senator where you said the ukrainian
people will ultimately succeed we had
alexander venman on in the last half
hour and he said you know uh putin's
call for to put his nuclear forces on
high alert that he's not really
concerned about that he called that
nuclear uh saber-rattling do you feel
the same do you think we should be
worried about this
well i'm worried about it i certainly
deeply respect colonel vinman's service
and knowledge
and many of us have been debating
whether or not putin
remains the cold and calculating and
rational actor he's been
there seems to be something unhinged
about his recent speeches and
the boldness the aggression of his
invasion of ukraine the next few days
and weeks will show us whether or not
he responds to the deterrent force of
aggressive sanctions i don't think he
expected the entire western world to
come together against him and to impose
crippling economic sanctions technology
sanctions even seeing the sports world
excluding him and the eu shutting down
its airspace so we'll see whether he's a
rational actor i hope this is nothing
more than saber rattling but we should
be very concerned and very vigilant
about deterring putin from further
acting against the west
senator you're also on the senate
judiciary committee what's the timeline
for the confirmation hearings of
president biden's nomination of
contendry brown jackson
well judge jackson will begin meeting
with senators this week we'll begin
reading into her decisional record her
background
my hope is that we will have a
confirmation process that is fair that
is swift that is transparent and that
we'll see her seated on the supreme
court later this spring my hope is we'll
have a confirmation vote before easter
but senator what is the delay at all
when it comes to her background she was
just confirmed less than a year ago for
the federal circuit court of appeals
everything seems to be ready to go
that's right
typically the the
the judiciary committee had a long
tradition
of taking at least a few weeks to
give members to meet with a nominee to
read into their background um there's
two things at play here yes you're right
she was very recently confirmed to the
dc circuit
so we've recently had a chance to review
her record and she hasn't written many
decisions since she was confirmed it was
so recent but frankly also the precedent
of the confirmation of justice amy comey
barrett which was raced through in a
matter of just a few weeks
by the republicans under the previous
administration those two in combination
suggests this might be a rather swift
confirmation process it's going to be
interesting though because some
republicans are already calling her too
radical yes or no do you expect
bipartisan support on this
i would certainly hope so um she got
three republican votes when confirmed
for the d.c circuit she hasn't changed
in the last few months uh and she has
outstanding uh credentials a remarkable
background and she will make historic
contributions to our supreme court three
republican votes it's worth remembering
that when breyer who she would replace
was uh confirmed he got 87 republican
votes or 87 votes 87 to 9 was the vote
so very bipartisan we're in a different
world that's right no one disputes our
qualifications thank you senator coons